taking a step back he's doing great on
the clock that's the one uh good thing
for him he's lost control but he's still
miles ahead on the clock and okay big
threat in the position we talked of
knight forks if that black knight
continues its journey to the e2 square
checking the white king and hitting the
white queen black will win so uh anish
needs to move one of those two pieces
but he can just move his queen to her to
the earth
are they agreed to draw oh how about
i think it is a draw wow why why why why
the draw is like a loss this is the best
position you've had for a long time why
the game is still alive there's still
chances you've got knights and queens i
mean just see just on the board right
yeah see what nisha's next move is at
least you know he might lose his queen
unlikely but you never know i think he
should be deducted a huge amount of
points on the fighting chesses that uh
index for that one yeah antare well we
know you've said it before david he's a
very emotional player and you can just
see it on him he's very disappointed
aryan he wasn't able to put up a fight